the city of Boston has many great
attributes but The Treasure of the North
End is its outstanding Italian food
served at over 150 Italian restaurants
the first fine dining establishment in
this neighborhood was Dobby day which
opened in 1982. it's everyday back in
the Heyday it was the number one Italian
Restaurant in Boston it was incredible
it was always a line at the door what's
the name if you didn't make reservations
three weeks in advance you could not get
in in 1997 van matre D Frank and his
brother Anthony fulfilled the dream by
purchasing Davide at the height of its
popularity this is amazing when we
bought the restaurants we were making
money I felt like we hit a gold mine are
they liking the Chicken special they're
liking it I'm working with Frankie and
my life is wonderful
the restaurant started off strong but
within the first couple years Fred found
out that Anthony was embezzling money
I went into the account whenever I
needed money I would if I had access I
would take money to you know buy
painkillers whatever
he was addicted to painkillers heroin
he's been in detox in jail he's out of
jail the responsibility of keeping
anything open it was always
my shoulders basically there was no one
else there to help it's 3 30. you got to
get ready for dinner it's definitely
gonna get [__] anyways tonight no
you're not when Anthony left Frank gave
up
he's broken mentally and physically oh
my God
since I've been back I am not the same
person Hi good evening I'm in recovery
I'm doing well those days are behind me
I'm here I'm responsible and I'm making
a restaurant a priority right this way
let's forget about the past and move on
and I don't think he has I don't think
he can shut the [__] up take the food
that's up in the window and come back so
yeah go away but at the same time he
should take some responsibility of
giving up and not putting the whole
blame on me because of what I did
Anthony
stop I'll kill
he's not at his best this is it you know
he has no more chances it's all over do
[__] hot water get the [__] up don't
waste my time
Frankie will not listen to me hey this
is your tape get the [__] out of here
really it's all you know just turret and
and spiteful
why don't you go kill yourself
[Music]
I think that Frankie has a lot of pent
up anger and resentment towards Anthony
if it can't be put aside I really can't
see the restaurant succeeding
it's killing them
we need help extremely badly because
we've been living month to month are we
going to be able to take checks this
week if we close the door tomorrow we
would be out with a million dollars
[Music]
always have the conflict that's why Chef
Ramsay I think is the answer to help us
things don't turn around we will close
the doors
right the only way to understand is
Boston properly is jump on one of these
trolleys because those guys have really
got their fingers on the pulse
North End please one of my favorite
places you ever heard of the Russian
Derby Day well it's funny you say that
it's on our tour route we drive by it
probably four times a day and I don't
know anybody that's really ever gone
that's not good news it's not great news
so many restaurants in Boston and we
recommend many of them and I don't know
a driver that really recommends David
unbelievable
[Music]
wish me luck good luck it's Happy Days
nice to see you guys good to see you
buddy
down below
whoa hello how are you hello how are you
very good nice to meet you good to see
you Anthony Gordon Ramsay good to see
you buddy you are the I want to be
honest one of them my brother Frank okay
for the kitchen what a quiet little
place and how long have you owned it
um 1997. what was the last thing you
changed her we did the books over and we
um took the wallpaper off we haven't
changed as much with the times I believe
time moved on and Frankie stayed right
in 1997 and uh he won't change but can't
they and just gave up that's simple
let's get everybody together and have a
proper start meeting here that looks
good thanks Anthony hello hi Maria
oh wow okay you work here as well she's
the negotiator and this is I'm Deborah
who's your wife yeah okay great Frank
Frank good to see you buddy and Frank is
your big brother yes fantastic hi I'm
Kim I'm pranks wife please take a seat
please first of all let's find out the
truth how long has it been slow at least
a good three years and you're in the
kitchen you cook my job was in the
dining room all my life right we're in
the restaurant in the kitchen I learned
they picked up how did you buy it my
mother gave me the money and me and my
brother ended up buying them together
okay so it's literally a 50 50 business
everything's supposed to be 55th right
what does that mean help me out Anthony
has been in and out of the restaurant
over the 13 years
[Music]
some painkillers I took money gone in
trouble went to jail the whole nine
yards
I went to seven this week by myself
Frankie got left with the whole [__] and
got to him got depressed and got burnt
out money went down every year naturally
I did damage to the business but you
cannot get over the past if you can't
put the past behind you we can't go on
when you've been burned six times it's
hard to say yeah okay that's in the past
Anthony is trying to make amends
everything he's done is being criticized
every little thing is being nitpicked
he's lost because of the past
you know everything is Anthony Anthony I
think he doesn't take any blame for
anything that's happened anywhere is
that right
it was a foot of me to blame I was gone
the business it was like abandoned
and nothing was done Anthony you've
ruined the business
you've destroyed it
I never want to be in a restaurant by
myself
I mean come on oh man I'm pissed I'll
[__] tell you to go [__] yourself for
the [__] you put me through oh my
God fine Anthony never apologize never
it's like kid don't you understand what
you've done you put me in the position I
am now but I like to [__] beat him up
and the problem I think
he doesn't respect me for anything
because the past everything and I don't
respect them because I think he laid
down and [__] died wow
within minutes of his arrival Chef
Ramsay was confronted with the bad blood
that exists between the two brothers
Anthony you've ruined the business and I
don't respect them because I think he
laid down and [__] died and while his
relationship with Anthony is at the
breaking point Frank wants to prove that
his cooking skills have not suffered
thank you and this is Andrew Andrew
thank you Andrew recommendations there
isn't a bad thing on the menu Caesar
salads made right in the dining room yep
okay good nice there is great potential
here we just need someone like Gordon
Ramsay to come in because if the
relationship between Frank and Anthony
is kind of sabotaging the restaurant all
the pastas handmade has a big positive
all the pasta is handmade yeah all
handmade that's incredible
let's start off with you yeah sure gotta
go for the season table saw I'd love
that idea and the fresh Lobster ravioli
all right the racket I'll go for that as
well I want to see as much as I can and
travel across Italy yeah brilliant yep I
hope so
I think it Concord trying to push it out
when the attitude's there when he wants
to ah how's Frank 47 47. he looks older
than that
stress jeez
what's he having what's up with the
involtini don't talk to me just write it
down all right
talking to Nova I'm nervous but like at
the same time it's like come on bring
the Tesla I know I could pass I'm not
blowing my own smoke on my ass but that
food is good prepare the season anybody
got the season going
[Music]
Brilliance tableside Caesar and North
End of Boston right yep are you going
right to the very Basics you've got an
egg yolk there as well egg yolk garlic
anchovies wow who'd ever thought I'd be
making a Caesar for Gordon Ramsay
thank you
[Music]
I love doing the Caesar salad so I put a
lot of enthusiasm into it
foreign
[Music]
have you just washed that salad yes you
just washed it there yeah because it's
soaking wet
so all the dressings just run off it
because the lettuce is soaking wet to
dress a seed salad the salad has to be
crisp but dry so you've made all that
freaking work for nothing oh my God
eight minutes for nothing
[Music]
okay we think he's gonna like the food I
think so Frank is so defeated right now
that he's lost the confidence in himself
as a chef and in his abilities the
eggplant is in the window when I get it
out Andrew
[Music]
the addiction what was it painkillers
pancakes
[Music]
really never been in trouble with the
law before that
that was the first time happen to be the
FED how long do you spend inside oh
almost four years have you been clean
for how long now almost two years that's
fantastic yeah two years two Brilliance
yeah it's nice
and here we have the eggplantini de
malanzani thank you
[Music]
soggy hasn't been fried or cooked long
enough
yeah it was really spongy and horrible
are they Frozen no no that's fresh when
were they done this morning ready we
just check if that was done this morning
because it tastes like it was done last
week what's up
right what so this is spongy what was it
when were they made
ah you asked me if they were frozen they
said no no three weeks ago yeah there's
a patch of freezer they don't make them
too hard every day
I can't make eggplants oh that's
impossible I don't have time
it's gonna be gonna get in here at 11 in
the morning
it's impossible to be here at 11 in the
morning
Frank is very lazy cook you know the
name of Friday eggplants anymore my
mother and father end up crying
ridiculous
and I can't made yesterday it was
actually made three weeks ago
yep
three weeks ago
that's disgusting you go grocery
shopping three weeks in advance before
you're gonna eat the stuff no
I'm talking about me oh that should be
fine
what's next
and with these mates yesterday
I'll make sure I get a date on that
looks like a goo
remember the lobster ravioli me I don't
know the manufacturer does that they are
not homemade
I definitely feel dumb you know here I
am telling people all the passes are
handmade because that's what Frank told
me I feel betrayed and My Own Boss
it's not right
nasty
the last ravioli is store-bought so it's
not fresh no
hold on we're backtracking now fresh
pasta every day all the past has been
made yeah all handmade I thought they
were made fresh
why would you have to store bought
that's gross you can never say to Frank
Frank why aren't the pastors hear me why
don't you come in earlier and make
pastas so I hope that you can get
through to him because he is a good Chef
what is he a passionate chef
[Music]
geez okay um thank you Andrew
you say you liked it you didn't like it
you hated the lobster ravioli
I really want to please the guy I know
he's gonna complain I mean come on at
least like tell me if the sauce was good
that's all I ask she doesn't like this
then like what the [__] I'm busting
again
you just gotta like something
just serve the name God let the Rosemary
crust and then the Barillo red wine
sauce Bon Appetito thank you
what kind of crust is it Rosemary
Rosemary Pat
burnt and bitter when garlic Burns it
goes bitter guy can't even taste lamb
I brought them back by some of the
dishes that came out
wow and again passion gone Anthony take
me to the kitchen please I'm gonna have
a word with Frank
I'm definitely Danford squealed
okay let's start I sat down I got told
the pasta is fresh I got excited it's
homemade and it's it's coming from the
heart
all of a sudden you've got this ravioli
Lobster that's store-bought
it was horrible but how was the sauce
talking [__] about the sauce The Filling
is the magic where there's a ravioli
tortellini it's the filling you get
excited about
the eggplant but that was a disaster
spongy bitter undercooked and then I got
told it was cooked three weeks ago
embarrassing I mean it's really
embarrassing you can't make fresh food
and freeze it and charge money to
running a [__] business if you kind
of be bothered to cook fresh food what
do you want me to do
wave your magic wand and turn this place
around come on
that's what I do I don't know how to do
any better that's the way you could do
much better or do you want to do better
[Music]
that's the big question
let me get some fresh air I'll be back
later yeah
unbelievable 13 years I've been here
Chef Ramsey tasting the menu was like
the worst experience I've ever had
okay now
this time decent yeah but you can't be
begging for a compliment Frank yeah
at the end it's always like something
Frankie thinks he knows everything he's
not gonna have it from anyone you'll
need help he may say [__] Ramsey too I
don't know it comes down to us being
here and not being her friend you know
it I know it it's not news you have
someone here willing to help you
do you want to learn from them dead
seriously dead seriously
I don't know well you have to make a
decision today
[Music]
upset after Chef Ramsay's harsh critique
of his dishes do you want to do this I
don't know Frank is not only questioning
the future of dovey day but his own
[Music]
definitely when I'm out the restaurant
is total frustration because there's so
many bad old memories
where's Frank oh they're there Christ if
we go down there a little booth
I'm thinking come on
you need to sit down on your ass to
think
my seat of depression
[Music]
your boss represents the company if you
see a boss slacking off what's that tell
you I mean he doesn't even dress up in a
chef's jacket who am I busting my ass
for was seemingly the weight of the
world on his shoulders
Frank is about to face a busy night as
word is leaked out that Chef Ramsay is
at Dobby day
back in the kitchen Frank
come on it appears as though Frank has
given up before dinner has even started
Frank come on come on come on come on
the only reason why I don't quit is
because I'm too proud let's go one
salmon one tag one shrimp afraid enjoy
your dinner as orders continue to pile
into the kitchen waiting on a duck and a
salmon I got the duck right here can I
call it table 20 please table 20. a
depressed Frank tries to get motivated
what's up on table ten zap three eight
point three back yeah I'm [__] it up
right now but it's not long before the
kitchen is backed up
[Music]
hey Anthony throw it the [__] down what
do you think I'm doing shut up I know
what you want my brother I hate this
attitude I hate work on him because like
I can't tell Frank anything without him
telling me to go [__] myself table 31
but wait in an hour please shut the [__]
up
talk to each other if you guys say
nothing it's just like the blind leading
the blinds well I think Ramsey it's
great because it's like he's the only
one who's going to listen to table ten
if we like the storm I'm waiting on 32.
can't cook that fast I need every
necklace
rush rush rush what the [__] is it with
the society I need I need two bolognes
right up behind ready yeah they're gonna
send this back it's all right start
cooking another one because they're
gonna send it back
this goes to table five do it now fish
was bad I was like ah [__] let her
roll they took a gamble I mean it
doesn't look pretty but they like it
they like it if not
[Music]
I'm sorry
who drive
what did I tell you Frank you knew that
was coming back
why did you send it he said he's gonna
get a complaint either way they're gonna
wait too long but they're gonna send it
back I'd rather they wait and have it
perfect and wait and send [__] to come
back
sad is that
[Music]
when a chef doesn't care that means the
restaurant goes downhill rapidly and
that's exactly what's happening tonight
I think Frank is way too burnt out right
now it's more depressing than anything
unbelievable
it's an hour and a half into dinner
service table 20 and table three that's
what I'm putting up and food is slowly
making its way out to the diners
but unfortunately it's not worth the
wait
Frank this is lukewarm yes son of a
[__] [__]
getting your [__] lemon juice [__]
stupid chicken out of your [__]
[__] pardon me
he says it's overdone shut the [__] up
just waited don't come back with it
this is that this has no breaking point
of this restaurant right here food sucks
anyways now putting up [__] [__]
Frank needs to make a commitment to
working hard and if you don't have that
passion you don't have it and you got to
get out of here any little [__] slips
coming in
Frank quit screwed I'm not [__]
cooked I'm not doing it
what you don't like it this is lukewarm
too dry he says it's overdone it may
only be halfway into dinner service
but owner Frank has had enough
[Music]
I might not go back in tonight I've
definitely lost the passion for cooking
not for being in the restaurant business
period
I don't know what to do anymore
with Frank abandoning the kitchen sous
chef Eddie and the rest of the staff
finish off a painful dinner service
[Music]
folks thank you very much have a good
night
[Music]
tonight I saw something quite
frightening
wasn't a bad food wasn't the complaints
and it certainly wasn't the service
Frank
[Music]
and here's why
watching him he is so burnt out
he's given up it's like a ticking Time
Bomb that's about to explode
I know
[Music]
see now my job for the years he's done
for everyone
hey
[Music]
I can see it that's why we called you
because we want to help this is not
about a guy that can't be bothered to
cook he is done he's on the floor I know
and he's barely breathing
what have we done
we start by bringing him back tonight
take 10 minutes out and think of
something you've never said in before
that can help to inspire him to
understand yes good night good night
thank you very much
if I could stop anybody he's got a good
heart I think he thinks I'm against them
it's really not like that you know it's
my brother
I love him
but if we can't work together without a
doubt we will close the doors
[Music]
Frank has clearly lost his passion and
unfortunately his family and his
business are being dragged down with him
let's uh sit down Chef Ramsay knows that
if this restaurant has any chance of
surviving he must find a way to inspire
Frank take a seat
when I watched you last night from start
to finish it upset me and here's why I
witnessed a Broken Man
I could see all the stress has killed
your spirit
I spoke to Kim and Anthony late last
night and they both just want to say
something to you personally
Anthony wrote it down quite a fact of
speech
frankly both no we're not good at this
stuff so
all right
Frank I think you'll have been so
overwhelmed for so long and for good
reason
I know how much damage I've done
[Music]
big deep breath it's all right
and you had to hold it together
now I believe you need to take care of
yourself you and I both know that you
have it in you to get back into life no
matter what we say to each other you
know if it comes down to it I'm always
there I think we lost sight of what we
really count I believe we can really
make this place work you know that we
can if we put the effort into it we
don't ever say it but I do love you
that's it
my brothers never that's the first time
I heard any rumors from him
legitimate remorse
should I listen and show a lot listen
no okay
to say I love you is an understatement
and to say that I'm always beside you I
think you know that the past 12 years
have been the hardest of our lives but
we made it through together
because we love each other and I will
get the way you talk to people lately
and the mean things that come out of
your mouth and I think it comes from you
holding this burden for the whole family
for so long on your shoulders
you haven't put this Chef Jack on in
four years
because I think inside you felt you
didn't deserve it anymore but you do
you're actually one of the most talented
people I've ever met in my life that
lack of passion that showed in the food
yesterday for Gordon was a cry for help
you are worth it and you deserve success
and you've worked hard for it and you
deserve it right but the only way this
place is gonna make it is you have to
look within you and break down this wall
that you've built
[Music]
please put this back on
no I'm serious
I don't deserve to wear that jacket
because schmuck could put up the food I
was putting out you don't wear a uniform
if you don't produce put it back on not
yet
after an emotional we don't ever say it
but I do love you and hopeful plea from
his family please put this back on not
yet Chef Ramsay goes to work I don't
care about the [__] that's been kicked
into you years ago you gotta cook trying
to reignite Frank's passion in the
kitchen I want you to think of something
that you want to cook and put the
passion on the plate not the anger
Ramsay is doing like a freaking thing
that I made yesterday I don't know what
to do to please the guy what are you
thinking of doing oh my God it's total
blank
I hope you think she's good fans say
this in a simple limit giveaway line
nice I'd like to see your mind working
yeah
it means your passion's coming back
Frankie has a talent to put out that
kind of food if he gets dedicated it
could be done if not it's over before
you go in the sauce Charlotte's time a
little dash of Rosemary
no good
it's delicious
oh good [__] [__] me a new ass walk
there have I got served that yesterday's
my entree I'd be like a pig and [__]
he liked it cooking with Chef Ramsey
made me feel like I was cooking at the
old days the way I had passion about
doing things absolutely delicious good
now that Frank's Spirit has been lifted
Chef Ramsay decides to go ahead with
phase two of his plan giving a facelift
to the tire Decor of Davide
good morning Frank how are you so
nervous great
let's go come in come in come in oh my
God look at this nice oh beautiful
welcome to the UW day right where should
we start a new modern appeal
God are the old Dreadful chairs
nice we've replaced it with stunning new
mahogany chairs beautiful
okay take a look at this that is awesome
by replacing those Dreadful White Walls
above the stone we've contemporized the
dining room now we've got textured
material it's lit underneath it is going
to look absolutely beautiful and what
about the Derby Day sconces are they
beautiful they are absolutely gorgeous
have a look at these boots you know he's
swapped the banquets
for the Boost this is now a fresh modern
Vibe absolutely beautiful
everything is perfect Gordon we couldn't
have asked for anything more these were
things that we were never able to do
and to see if we can cry it's
overwhelming
in that hand there's grave for 27 years
now it's like totally everything is
different and modernized I can feel it
that the hope is coming back
you can't please put that away Frankie
please you need to wear a chef's coat
because you're a chef take this off and
please please for me you're a chef
you're really here
first time I wore a jacket it's 40 years
I don't want people to know I was a chef
back here
[Music]
the right way they're looking nice see
him put on the coat
to meant that yes I'm taking this all
seriously and it's it just means a lot
to me
and now you look like it's the chef that
you are because you can do it
touching settlement for her wife but
Jack it doesn't make the person
gives you a way to go there but it
doesn't make the person now that Frank
appears ready to command the kitchen
it's time for the Final Phase of Chef
Ramsay's plan the menu have a look at
this wow oh my God the future of diving
day is right in front of your eyes on
the table it looks so nice gone are the
Dreadful plates of the 80s
the appetizers bruschetta roasted
Peppers the cake of various marinated
baby Tomatoes burrata how could we be a
modern Italian restaurant without any
burrata then the pierce the Renaissance
is the main course homemade gnocchi
ground butter truffle oil and some fresh
chives at the end homemade stress that
every time homemade yeah pork tenderloin
Frank your chicken lemon chicken we've
got an onion compote on there as well
tonight we relaunch the modern Davida
dig in there's no one
change the whole menu into what it needs
to be for this type of a city with this
many restaurants and that's what's going
to set us apart from all the others the
chicken I like it though
it's only an hour before dinner service
and Chef Ramsay has one more important
message for Frank
Anthony is never gonna be perfect in
your eyes but for a recovering addict to
be clean for two years it was good well
it's it's not bad I wish my brother was
clean I wish he had kicked his habit
there were a similar age
and the crap that we go through on a
daily basis is just extraordinary but
cut him some slack and get him by your
side help him because I think
when you start helping him he's going to
come back 10 times over
as well yeah
[Music]
maybe I've been so tough with Anthony me
and Anthony have to work together and
turn the restaurant around yeah of
course it's gonna be hard it's never
gonna be easy no nothing ever it is if
you want it you can do it
I know you can do it I won't let you
down so you got my fashion back it's so
amazing that this is coming up
[Music]
it's relaunch night at Derby Day
kill time guys and Frank is already
feeling the pressure holy Mary Mother of
God I never thought this nervous before
I don't want to disappoint anybody and I
want to prove it to myself I can't do it
but Chef Ramsay has some important
information that is going to make the
evening even more intense I've just had
a call listen to me yeah tonight you've
got the Boston magazine coming in as
well
tonight the stakes were raised from the
beginning so our eyes wide open yeah and
now we're going to be Boston magazines
in the restaurant and that's a big deal
I'm ready to go you're welcome
right this way please
with the restaurant packed Boston
magazine have just arrived 15.
first tickets are in and Frank is about
to face his first big test all right
five's coming up all the tables of high
priority
right here let's watch the magazine it
affects the business think about the bad
review that's pretty enjoy
[Music]
this is really good I would love the
recipe I would love to make this out
well the critics from the Boston
magazine are clearly pleased with their
appetizers it's great they aren't the
only ones oh
and for the first time in a long time
yeah it's excellent this quaint dining
room in the North End of Boston is
buzzing Frank a new order just came in
but back in the kitchen
expediter I need entrees on table 12
immediately okay
Frank talk to each other a little bit
yeah yeah the mood is starting to turn
and the tension is building between the
brothers
the second cause and I got a knock in a
pizzelli right now as Anthony pushes
Frank to finish the Boston magazines
entrees keep it together come on
coordinator yes table 15 fact and that
cost two ravioli one pork yes yes we
start at 15. it's very rare the Boston
magazine come out like that I'll drop it
out and that walk is working fine please
can I get the port so I could complete
come on Frank we haven't got the other
two give me they said don't ever rush me
come on give me give me give me enough
when it's ready give me go thank you
this cork is a little wrong should we
send it back
what's not good yeah it's still a little
bit you want it more cold it's like pink
but not red you know
I want to make a good impression oh my
God but what's a disaster table 15.
[__] it's the Boston magazine oh my God
we're so [__] right it's gonna be the
biggest [__] in Boston in five
minutes now yeah come on the one awesome
came back that table had to come back
this is a [__] disaster oh
[Music]
it's Dobby day's grand reopening
critical mistake at the Boston magazine
table two Rock rank the pork [__] Mr
Boston magazine
has Frank's confidence completely shaken
oh my God we're so [__] got another
one going what's up what's up what I
want to communicate okay let Jeff Ramses
I want to let myself down and let
everybody down
people have come back
what's not the table
listen I've been put this back you can
pull it back come on okay
we can get it going yeah I'm [__]
pissed
I always went back to the old ways but I
took a deep breath and I was like okay I
gotta refocus it I'm not giving up I'm
tired but I'm not good enough
there you go here's the four seconds we
find that's 15 take it out come back
strong yeah let's go
oh God I was gonna impress you tonight
make sure it's good
[Music]
I'm kind of excited to see what happens
21 cable 23 pick up hey YouTube continue
talking we're gonna get there yes sir
good a relationship with Anthony I'm
still fractured that's what's holding us
back in the restaurant but he's been
trying harder I see it so I'm willing to
compromise with Anthony supporting Frank
in the kitchen Anthony nice come on guys
bring it together over there beautiful
welcome Manning
the two brothers complete dinner service
on a high it's a long restaurant to me
every night
[Music]
wow what a nice yeah good in bed trust
me mostly good
think back to my first day here I saw a
family in turmoil
and a chef that was sitting down in the
kitchen depressed
but tonight I saw a family come together
and pull off a strong service
Frank you proved to me tonight that you
can run a kitchen
the way you handle the pressure was
phenomenal yes I feel grateful beyond
words
for Frankie to hear Gordon say that you
can do this a hundred percent it just
means so much because he deserves this
can't say thank you enough
and Frank
keep that chef jacket on keep that
attitude with it
and never
sit down in a kitchen ever again
I'm rooting for your success
I'm really excited for the future my
goal now is to keep the passion going
this is a new day for the everyday
guys good luck yes yes good luck good
luck good luck and more importantly
just thank you [__] passionate man in
there with a lot to give okay don't stop
don't crack your smile from time to time
yeah
there's no words that you could describe
what I'm feeling right now it's
overwhelming totally overwhelming
tonight
thank you
the last 10 years Boston has seemed to
ignore Davide for now with this huge
turnaround with the food and the staff
it's got every right to return to its
former glory
oh my God
people think I've got a funny accent
geez
in the weeks that followed Frank's
rediscovered passion for cooking
flourished
give it one at a time he's back in love
with food hot I want to make myself
proud my family proud and Chef Ramsey
Crow and the City of Boston is reaping
the benefits
as for his brother Anthony yes thank you
beautiful he too has made a comeback
very nice to see you on that he is
clearly committed to the restaurant very
good thank you and more importantly to
his brother
[Music]